dernière question à propos de cet
ouvrage est ce que vous pensez qu'un
jour ce que des crimes sur orbite
eh bien nous le verrons parce que
simplement il a peut-être fait un peu
d'anticipation
est-ce qu'on peut le voir sur les
anticipations et aux lilas je crois
s'est fâché prématuré non je pense que
les problèmes éthiques qu'il a soulevés
sont évidents mais je répète ce que j'ai
dit il n'est pas exclu que ça se fasse
alors ça posera des problèmes à chérir
romaine nous sommes telles pas là ce
soir pour anticiper de cette façon est
ce que vous savez vous le souhaitez pour
du tout présente pour vous avez dit tout
à l'heure ce qu'il fallait dire les
voies naturelles bien quand même encore
de l'avenir
et surtout qu'est ce que ça représentait
ce progrès technique
ça représenterait un saut en arrière
d'un milliard d'années
il ya un milliard d'années nous avons
inventé la sexualité et la façon d'y
mettre à deux pour faire un troisième
set autrement plus astucieux parce qu'à
chaque fois c'est quelqu'un nouveaux cas
par an que de se re doublé car
finalement à quoi cela servirait à
éviter si je me fais un jumeau de mourir
or ce n'est pas vrai j'ai l'impression
que le nommé max s'il a jamais existé ou
s'il existe un jour aura une angoisse de
la mort tout aussi grande
ayant ainsi mots que s'ils n'en avaient
pas eu finalement sert à rien